welcome back to las vegas now i'm rocky
fields and it is time to get cooking
with nanny bubby she is joining us
live via skype to share a delicious
recipe for a lasagna
cast iron skillet dinner hey nanny bubby
hey
rocky how are you i'm sorry a little bit
before you how are you doing
i'm doing great it is nice to see you
live again
yes nice to work with you twice so i
wanted to just tell you
that i challenged myself to do about a
20-minute prep and get it all done in
about five minutes so if you hang in
there with me
i'm gonna go ahead and uh and tell you
what we're doing we're making
a skillet pan cast iron pan lasagna
all in one pan you know sheep and
dinners are really big things
these days yeah so we're going to do
this in a cast iron skillet
and if you don't have one this is called
a lodge
you can pick it up at any hardware store
so if you want to get started
with a cast iron skillet this is the one
to get started with
this one's a little too small for me so
i'm using this bigger one
and what i started with is some onions
and i put salt on the onions so that i
could sweat it
i love saying that because all the best
chefs say sweat your onions
because that helps them brown just a
little bit more quickly
i added a pound of hamburger meat to
this and this is sausage
chicken spicy italian sausage and we're
adding this
in i can smell it from here i
love it i can smell that cooking we're
gonna put in a little bit
of red chili flakes for a little spicy
add some extra spice to it and we're
going to saute this down
now this will take about 7 to 10 minutes
what you want to do
is make sure that the meat is not pink
anymore
we don't have time for that so i'm just
going to speed ahead
and just tell you that you're going to
add then this
entire can of crushed fire roasted
organic tomatoes
and about three quarters of a jar of my
favorite
liquid gold or raviota sauce by rayo's
now that's going to be really runny and
really liquidy
but you then are going to let it cook
down
until it gets nice and rich and thick
about seven to i don't know 10 minutes
and you can see that the sauce is very
rich and very thick
so all of that sauce and liquid cooks
down you're going to
transfer it into a bowl just like i did
don't worry if you don't scrape the
bottom out
because you're just going to add it back
in and here we go we're going to layer
ready we've got you're going to do
that oh i'm so glad you like it and
party and filling will fill well yeah
the whole family
yes and here's the next tip you want to
do this
with no boil lasagna noodles
they come from trader joe's it's the
best place to find them
they come in this size of a sheet we're
going to crack them in half
and just lay them right here on top of
the meat
i love trader joe's they always have
everything ready for you i'm telling you
you know i always have my favorite
places so
just layer them in there we go
we're going to put that on top then
we're going to do a dollop of this
ricotta now if you notice their
favorite the next tip the egg in here
is not for anything but it helps to hold
the ricotta together because when it
hits the heat
it just starts to get milky and you
don't want that so the egg and the
ricotta will keep that from happening
okay we're gonna take there we go we're
gonna take the
dollop of ricotta and spread it right
over the top
okay our mouths are watering over here
mozzarella and parmesan and sprinkle
that on top
just like that
a little bit more our camera guy said
dunk the whole bowl
yeah and then sprinkle a little more
parmesan and then you're going to start
the layer all over again so you're
starting with the meat
all over again whoop get it
oh yeah yeah now because we're running
out of time what we're going to do
is i'm going to show you layer this just
up just like i did about two layers
okay gotta lick that finger so i can
take us over
yes to the um magic
oven here sorry i gotta get the mitts on
and
then you can see look at this is this
gorgeous oh my gosh
my gosh do you see that let me put this
here
kick this oven closed we're going to
pair this with we're going to stick a
little
basil in there a little bit of the chef
and odd right there
wow and then pour a glass of wine and
you are set
yes and that's it wow with a green salad
we're all done
you you never cease to amaze us
good thank you so much nanny bubby we
always love your recipes check out nanny
bubby's kitchen and garden
on social media and online at
nannybubby.com we also want to thank
chapman automotive for sponsoring that
segment